folks Chris waters here on the GameSpot
stage thanks for sticking with us during
our comprehensive coverage of e3 2014
joining me on stage a man behind one of
the games that Sony is touting a lot
this year Paul Richardson Rosinski
I had it it was my first time Paul rich
in ski from evolution studios thank you
for joining me
so sorry about the names great debate oh
thank but driveclub
yes rival Club had a great showing
yesterday at Sony's press conference and
we won't know you guys got setups over
here people in some pods racing with the
wheel trying it out how's it going for
you it's been fantastic yeah everyone's
been able to get hands-on play with Club
versus Club online racing get to try out
the new Thrustmaster teeth we hundred
wheel on the pods and also this morning
we announced weather so that's dynamic
rain dynamic snow and it's been a great
start to e3 for us well I love the
context because it's taught weather is
so impactful when it comes to racing
because there's a tire choice is that
but saying that you announced weather do
you ever like crack a smile anytime to
do that like guys guys we got this great
new thing when but yeah you know that
that is such a factor in terms of your
you're driving tactics and what speed
you're coming into corners what kind of
car you want to drive changes gameplay
all together yeah I mean it's not just
about that obviously it's gonna make it
slippier but it's not having to change
your tactics as you drive because it
might start dry go wet then dry up again
so you having to react on the fly and
it's surf example it's in the snow at
night visibility just becomes a
nightmare because you know you're
missing what your four wins on or you
can see is a snow rushing towards the
windscreen it's your basic horribly
irresponsible yeah but that's why you
have video games absolutely love them
and that's you know that that transition
of weather is brings up something that I
think is really interesting about the
game you can you can do some custom
settings and set it to be a race that
you know goes through a whole day night
cycle goes through a bunch of different
weather cycles without having a be
excessively long yeah you've got full
control over any type of day and how
fast it transitions and you can do the
same thing with the weather as well now
so you can say I want the race to start
wet and then end dry or in a transition
through various states throughout the
race you can
totally decide all that and then if you
want to send us a challenge and anywhere
else to participate in that challenge us
gets to play the exact sim you know race
that you did and so you know throwing
challenges out there throwing down the
gauntlet actually that's something I
want to get into because it's such an
intricate part in integral part of your
your game sort of the social ecosystem
but first give us some context for what
we're actually watching on screen okay
this is this is our racing wheel demo
that Carl's playing right now and he's
just literally racing through I think
Chile right now in the Ferrari f12 and
we're just showing off base just how
good the game looks in this instance
this haven't this actually didn't have
any of the sort of connectivity normally
what you see if this was connected
online right now you'd have what we call
face offs face offs are dynamic
challenges which get placed into the
world so for example the next corner car
could be driving around it and the new
challenge gets dropped in that could be
from a friend or from a club mate and it
might be trying to beat the best drift
score or beat the best average speed it
just means that whether you're in last
place like he is right now there's
always different things to try and do
the same thing we're all drives every
action you do inside the game whether
it's drifting drafting overtaking clean
racing your reward if you do it so and
the cool thing is if car was part of pub
right now it would actually be rewarding
his club as well because everything you
do contributes towards your book even as
your clock levels up you earn rewards
exclusively for your book so I can I can
stop playing the game for a few days
come back at my club is unlock me a new
car you've got some new stuff because
you're rolling with the right club yes I
do you have to be exclusive though it's
going through practice club monogamy you
have to flip it completely exclusive yes
you have to be monogamous in drive club
all right because it means that I guess
when you get the elite clubs as well
you'll be fighting over best players
looks like you know we want to be the
best club in the entire world that means
we have to try and steal maybe the best
best best races around the world to be
in your club to reach the top of the
highest even think about that aspect of
it but you're totally right anytime you
get competition to an appropriately high
level that super high competitive level
then the players become you know we
always exposed to like football and
stuff where you're trying to you know
steal best players of different teams
it's like you know we want the best
players in our club absolutely so you
know you're working out some sort of
points or car transfer system in here
too
lure players away oh wow wait thought I
got you know sounds like a good idea
that you know otherwise it's just talk
fall all right I you know while you're
talking about sort of those active
challenges piping in reminds me of
something you said when talking about
the game in an article I was reading
before I like the idea you don't have to
be in first place yes you know and Paul
I like that idea too because I so rarely
am and I having something to still
strive for asides from the you know the
monolithic goal of get in front of the
next guy until they're normal guys to
get in front of really appeals to me as
someone who you know honestly is not
terribly skilled at racing game yeah and
that's one of key things are drive club
we want to appeal to a wider audience
the typical sort of simulator
you know playstation platformers Gran
Turismo and for those hardcore racers
that's amazing but we want to manage our
drive cover it's kind of this hiccup and
play racing game it's still got all the
depth and the you know the distinction
between all the various cars that handle
completely differently we want to make
sure people could pick up the game slam
down the hall and have a bit of fun if
you spend a bit more time with it
obviously be able to pull off you know
cool moves such as trail braking
Scandinavian flick set cetera you know
because every car you know truly is
unique and driveclub
absolutely I mean well what do you mean
by every car being truly unique well
what we try to do with every new car is
make sure that we captured it the
personality the essence because we were
lucky enough for this is what the Bears
and things about my job is I get to go
out drive a lot of these cars yeah yeah
yeah it done well they'll get just even
sitting inside one - turning on the
engine and listening to the engine no
other handling characteristics they are
so different you might think that you
know the Ferrari f12 and a Ferrari four
five eight you know have a few things
like crossover because they're from the
same manufacturer totally different
beast and we want to make sure we
represent everything from how it looks
how it sounds how it plays with every
can't we have and you guys have said you
know you travel around the world chasing
these high-powered high-performance cars
just so you can record them yet
it with a high fidelity and you're
pulling in like star charts from NASA to
populate the nighttime skies like what
is the what sort of the end goal of all
of that deep attention to detail it's
just one of the things that I guess our
DNA evolution we've got so many kind of
characters our art director our Corps
director they're all obsessed with
detail they want everything to be just
like real life and we're building this
engine so that we can go on to make up
against as well which capture all of
these amazing details at the future so
it's creating a platform for us to go on
and move forwards as well and so you
guys this is a whole new engine you're
building program and you from scratch
and you've done a little bit of sort of
revamping of it over the over the past
couple years right well our engine
obviously on PlayStation 3 that went
through a variety different cycles but
the new driveclub engine is built up
from the ground so there's nothing
that's been reused for any of our bolts
on tiles or de Bercy games because you
know the PlayStation 4 architecture is
totally different and we have to make
sure we harnessed every little bit of it
and you guys are certainly being
positioned as sort of one of these
showcase games right and Sony's like a
drive Club check this out this is what
it looks like to play on a Playstation 4
word it is you see all that you can see
Orion man like unless you're in the
southern hemisphere then you can only
see it on this one like yeah but do you
you know how is it how does it feel to
be sort of in that marquee position oh
it's fantastic I mean there's no better
position to be on the PlayStation 4
getting the support from Sony you know
showing it to the world so you know it's
it's amazing I mean we've done ports
torment the way I see it they've been
great games but I think Drive clubs
gonna blow all of those away and now
we're looking at that you know racing
here on another track seeing some open
open wheel cars up there we have one car
in the mix what kind of what's the
variety the sort of scope you guys have
set out for your cars off the car so
everything from hot hatches such as golf
wagon golf GTI's through to performance
cars such as Maserati GTS so super cars
such as primary f12 on the one you just
mentioned there's the BSE bono which is
a single seater cockpit racing car which
I've driven in Silverstone and it's
amazing experience and then we got hyper
cars such as the Hennessey Venom GT so
we've got like a really wide breadth of
cars but kind of ham picking the best we
think for me to those Mozart categories
mm-hmm now you you know you feel you've
been lucky enough to drive some of these
cars and that's obviously a thrill for
you
beside curiosity you guys have any
people had a little evolution who are
just like kinda crap drivers yeah like I
really love this stuff virtually but
like get me behind my minivan I'm just
gonna be alright the skill range between
people at evolution it is massive even
the petrol heads don't always play race
against that well but you get them on
the track in real life because we do
like karting days and stuff and they'll
blow you away
on the real track but yeah it's a sort
of game I think were more people in the
office have actually got into play more
just you know for fun because it is that
more accessible sort of game box dawn
was like seriously intense do BRC was
very simulation based so this is appeal
to you know all of us and we are major
petrol head to the evolution as well
well proper into our cars well you know
you're passionate about something that's
gonna show in your work and I think
that's definitely folks have found their
way to evolution they've probably are in
the right place yeah let's talk a little
bit about track design here as we head
into the mountains you guys do you have
actual tracks from the real world in the
game are these all sprung from your
imaginations well I want to say the
smoke from our imaginations because we
go to each these location so that's
Norway India Chile Canada Scotland and
we we sent them tiny mother who knew
full reference footage we capture things
like out beat all levels of the light
yeah thousands and thousands of pictures
have for reference etcetera and we we
try to take the essence of each these
locations and then transfer them to our
game so you won't see like a track like
silver saloon or you know Laguna SEC or
anything like that but you will see like
you know parts of the world and you'll
go if you've been to Norway you might
have been to this earlier you might
think this looks very familiar but all
the rods have been hump built to offer
that kind of the best gameplay suited to
drive Club very cool and so you know
when you're when you're building your
driving model right how these cars
handle you're constantly tweaking item
at constantly balancing constantly
making it feel right does that mean
you're also constantly tweaking the
tracks or do you sort of lay down the
tracks the way you like them and then
do the tweaking on the cars to make them
sort of feel right yes this is quite
what we tend to do is we we build the
tracks and then we develop our handling
model to work on those tracks but then
we do a little bit of tweaking on the
tracks but then we lock them down and
then it's all about doing the handling
tweaking okay we're still doing that
happens weaken right now we're going to
do it all the way up to the wire to make
sure we've kind of got every little
characteristics of the cars in the game
and let's be honest probably pass the
wire along into the life of drive club
well that's an interesting thing because
you know drag Club isn't just going to
be you know we'll put a disc out job
done we want to make sure that there's
going to be new features new content you
know reasons for people to keep laying
drive but after release so we're not
talked about all the details just yet
but I'm not going to lay out your whole
DLC planner but I think there's gonna be
a lot of things to keep people active
and playing drive club quite a while and
certainly one of those things is the
social integration that you guys are
really pushing and you know I I'm
actually curious sort of you know that's
a lot of this it's coming in during
gameplay it's connecting with your
PlayStation Network friends yeah is this
sort of stuff that you also with the
PlayStation 4 you got to contend with
the share button and play your feeds and
so how do you know how does that sort of
factor into the way you're structuring
this whole network
yeah well photo session 4 has a lot of
really cool social features which allows
us to kind of push activities out with
driveclub so it looks like you're on
your PlayStation dashboard and there's
new feature I think at the latest Bert
were called game alerts and so what we
can do when there's a new challenge or
something might refer to a club we can
tell you that even though you haven't
done its driveclub
so you know you'll be looking for all
your games watchdogs etc it's like oh
wait drive clubs trying to help me I've
got some new stuff so you can jump into
the game from from the game alerts
yeah and we've got driveclub app called
my drive book available on iOS and
Android and to be on to people today
with everything that's going on inside
where I put on the app as well as live
streaming people playing the game now
when you see everything that's going on
in drive Club that's a little daunting
so like let's say let's say I you know
me and my high school buddies were the
ninja clan drive club we've got you know
we're trying to like we're resurrecting
our old myth Marvel mid plan we're
playing I really care about like what
they are doing
of course I care about what they're
doing what other stuff do you want to
let me know about you
like the dudes at the top like racing
for you know flips and whatnot like sort
of how do you calibrate the level of
messaging you deliver to the player and
this has been a really difficult thing
to get right because you're always kind
of on this balance um is there too much
spam or am I not going to play enough
information yeah that's what we try and
do we've built a lot of information
relative to where you are inside the
game so if you're on the main menu we'll
give you a global overview of the main
things that happening inside your world
if you go into clubs you'll see
visibility of what's going on at your
club or clubs that you're connected to
if you go into challenges you'll see all
the latest challenges but there's also a
direct activity feed by betting triangle
any point will bring up your activity
fee which is basically stuff that's
specific to you so there's so many
different views on all this content so
you've always got the right information
at the right point very cool very cool
Paul it seems like drug clubs coming
along well you guys you know certainly
have a lot of ambition in terms of the
way you're trying to deliver on it just
on it purely technical level on a social
level and you know this is all coming
together it's coming out this year are
we gonna wait till 25th work out October
7th October 7 in the US that man is
gonna be murder man so honey game it's a
busy busy time but it's so much to get
excited about and the gamer yeah it's
amazing a lot of folks are getting into
driveclub
oh one more before you go I know you
mentioned this before and it was only
got a brief mention in the press
conference yesterday but talk to me
about
Morpheus VR ah that's a really exciting
piece of technology yeah it's not
something were actively developing for
October now but we do have a teammate
Evolution who are working with that
technology so checking it out and seeing
what might be in evolutions future for
the a bit more for you all right well I
just want to wait till III 2015 to find
that output Paul thank you so much for
coming on stage
driveclub shaping up really well October
7th is the release date for PlayStation
4 now ladies and gentlemen if you're
watching here on twitch.tv slash
GameSpot we're so psyched you are but if
you get on over to GameSpot you get
access to not just this stage but also
our other live stage where we have a
whole full slate of demos going there I
think
civilization 5 5 the
on earth is there even a number no it's
civil beyond Earth the new civilization
came just wrapped up over there a little
while ago
we've got more demos there as well as
reports from the show floor and all
kinds of on-demand video there for you
to check out so maybe swing over there
and check it out
but stick on this stage next we're going
to head up to see some Batman out on the
show floor and then it's back here for
an extra special double long demo of
middle-earth shadows of Mordor I as a
big Lord of the Rings fan I'm super
stoked for this one so don't go away